hey everybody it's Mike from overflows
and welcome to today's video and welcome
back to my channel you know if you've
been liking the videos I've been posting
recently uh be sure to hit the uh
subscribe button you know that uh you
know helps me get found by other Traders
and you know it gives me encouragement
to make more videos now today uh you
know today was an interesting day Market
had been selling off uh you know all the
European session and coming into the
cash session and we had a nice bounce
off of it let me just pull up a quick
bar chart here so you can see really
quick um you know what the market was
doing you know since uh 430 417 we
started making new lows uh we dropped
from about the 43 75 and a quarter all
the way down to 43.50 right when the
cash opened and then we rallied we
rallied all the way back up into the 80s
uh right now it's about 2 30 we're
trading around
43.81 and you know it's it's interesting
because oftentimes
you have you know you have different
market conditions and there's a market
condition that I like to call a flow
driven market and you know sort of
coming into
you know the US morning you know it
looked like we were in a flow driven
Market with a lot of uh strong selling
on the way down and it was on that cash
open that the market rebounded so let's
take a look at the order flow
um you know for any sort of signs of you
know a potential reversal taking place
that you know you could have taken
advantage of as a Trader now
again you know 8 30 is
you know going to be the busiest time of
the day up to that point right because
that is when you know the cash Market
opens in New York and you get all the
Algos kicking off in you know in the
Futures market so you know all the big
orders that generally will start during
the cash hours right so 8 30 that's when
all the big orders start executing now
you know and you can just see how the
volume changes right
the cash open bar this is a one minute
chart 26 000 you know the the bar right
before it was 6 000 and all the buyers
before it were um you know even a
thousand two thousand and even less than
a thousand so you know trying to analyze
sort of the order flow that's taking
place right ahead of the cash open you
got to realize right it's going to be
less volume and once that cash opens
it's almost sometimes it's like a whole
new ball game and you know when you're
selling off you know all night or all
morning into the cash open right going
lower lower just making new lows with
impunity taking out whatever volumes
were there and then you know and you
know at you know six in the morning four
in the morning five in the morning you
know you don't get the the same size
that's sitting on the bid or on the
offer that you would see normally during
the day session but nevertheless once we
opened right we we got that we hit that
low 43.50 and you know we traded all the
way up to 57 order so a seven point move
we close somewhere up near the top and
then what happens next bar also up and
that bar on the cash opened we had a
very strong negative Delta of 1485 and
it actually closed at minus 531 so you
know at one point it was close to minus
1500 we closed the bar at minus 500 so
there was another thousand contracts
that came in that was buying to change
that uh Min Delta for minus 1485 to just
minus 531 so that's important to note
right then obviously in the next candle
we saw some selling pressure early right
it had a strong negative Delta of 813.
Delta closed at 490 right maxed out that
was 492. so imagine it went from minus
to plus 490 so you know basically 500 so
that's a swing as well right very strong
negative Delta strong selling early in
the bar
and it closed positive but not only that
so it went from minus 800 back to zero
so that it gained 800 contracts back and
then Plus 490.
so it's almost 500 so for minus 800 back
to zero that's 800 plus another 490 500.
you know that's uh whatever that is uh
300 contracts right that's a big shift
in these two bars right that's the
internals you know it's funny because
somebody posted a comment on one of my
videos the other day saying you know
Delta doesn't matter anymore okay well
you know I think it does but to each
their own right I mean that's what makes
the markets right we all have
differences of opinion and differences
in what we think works for the market
there are some instances in the Delta
analysis that I think is very useful to
Traders still and what else do we see in
this bar here well we see a very thin
print in here we see two right I was
talking about the volume right at Price
levels at 43.59 when it was 59 bid at 59
and a quarter only two contracts traded
now this bar remember keep in mind it
traded eleven thousand
uh 770 contracts right 11 000 spot seven
seven k and here at this level you can
only get two and it's holding right it's
staying above that area now I have the
thin prints turned off but if I were to
turn them on
you know you're going to see it's just
it's really going to stand out a lot
more uh for you as a Trader and
here we go turn it on now again it's up
to you to decide you know what you want
to use as a thin print you know for a
market like e-minis I think you could
use up to nine but you know for today
you know we'll just use five right if
you you think nine is too much volume
now again you could use zero you could
stick with zero obviously you're going
to get a lot less but there's going to
be instances where there's zero I'll
just keep it at five I know Traders use
zero they use one three five nine
generally those are the numbers that uh
most of the Traders I talk to that used
in Prince will look at in the e-minis
okay obviously if you're trading
something like mini Dao you'd probably
want to keep it at uh two or three but
for e-minis you know it's a little bit
more subjective and depending on the
type of chart you're trading this is a
one minute chart you gotta understand
what sort of volume okay so I'll just
show you I setting it at five people say
well you only set it at five because
that's a two well okay fine if I set it
at zero it's not going to show up but I
know two is still a thin volume right
there's always got to be people out
there that got to throw stones at edit
at everything okay but still regardless
if it was
um two or zero that's still a thin
volume right Market next bar went up
didn't even pull back into that two
until about three bars later okay and
you can see there's even
prices from earlier but again you know
we'll just turn off the two we'll set it
to zero because I'm sure someone will
say well you know you're just cherry
picking this but again you gotta
understand
two contracts is still thin okay it's up
to you to decide and the default I think
on on North Post Traders actually set to
nine but if you have it at zero
nevertheless okay we'll just keep it at
zero and see you know where else the
zeros up here
um let's give it a second here to come
up and
you know so you have the Delta shift
right we saw that in these two bars
right after the cache open okay and then
we sort of go up and then go sideways
right we're just trading sideways
um more or less and then we sort of pop
back up again right sort of break out of
this little area between 67 and you know
62. so we're more or less trading in a
five range zone now you know another
thing that I like to use when I'm
looking at the order flow is the value
areas right the value areas of the bars
right now they're turned off but when I
turn them on let's take a look and see
how it looks okay value area engulfing
value area let's click apply and come on
you know we create all these tools to
help you as a Trader you know see things
a lot easier rather than sit here trying
to say oh what does this mean what does
that mean you know you want to be able
to identify things happening in the
order flow as soon as they happen okay
and what do we have here right well
right off this low we got an engulfing
value area which is bullish we have a
value area here that's not traded back
into in the next bar which is also
bullish
we have another value area which is not
traded back into the next bar also
bullish so what do we got we got three
bullish order uh value areas right off
the low we have a gap here in the value
between the value area high of this bar
and the value area low of this bar now
you know the the ICT boys out there
they're going to say oh you got a fair
value Gap right because I talk about
value gaps and when I talk about value
gaps in value what I mean is from the
value area of one bar to the value area
of another bar just as if you're using a
volume profile Market profile you would
talk about gaps in the value from one
day to the next day if there was was one
but you know ICT guys will say well you
have the high here of this bar in the
low of this bar and you have this void
you know the column voids
in here and you can see how the market
traded back in there okay there's a lot
of times
you know to me that's a bit like
Candlestick analysis it works when it
works when it doesn't work you know they
don't say anything but um it's clear
when you're looking at the actual value
areas to understand what's happening
right why does the market pull back you
know literally right to this level it's
that area where you have the thin volume
and you know that's where the end of the
value area was right just like in this
bar it trades back into this value area
okay so that's right off the bat you're
seeing a lot of bullish things in in the
market right you're seeing the Delta
change internally you're seeing the
value areas giving you some bullish
signs
um you're seeing some signs in the
volume actual volume of the order flow
that's giving you some nice bullish
signs right so as as we go up
um you know we get all the way up here
to uh was at 73 72 and a quarter come
off a bit and then just go sideways dip
down in here now we're starting to see
again some more bullish order flow
coming in here right the value area
that's abandoned value area that's
abandoned here's your zero print right
Market sort of works its way back up
where does this Market come back to and
it holds it comes right back to this
value area
right then it starts working its way
back up
um and it gets all the way back up into
the 70s again now here we've got a
bearish value area right that's not
tested we have a slingshot point of
control we have a zero print in there
and it's engulfing value area Market
starts to sell off just goes sideways
you know at this point this is where I
was looking for the market to
you know kind of really want to sell off
and the fact that it's just holding
inside there for one two three four you
know five bars finally gets passed it
here you know when you trade back into a
value area
there's
a couple things you want to pay
attention to one does it trade into it
and reject it like here where it trades
into it and starts rejecting it the best
ones are where they trade back into it
and reject it in the same bar and move
away from it pretty quick right you
don't necessarily want it to come back
in and sort of just you know spend a lot
of time trading in there just like we're
doing here right and eventually it
popped up because you know if you've
ever studied Market profile
um you know you know read all the books
on market profile you you should know
that you know the on a daily profile
right sometimes you know the best moves
of the day
come when you go back into the day's Val
you know the the value area and trade
all the way through right and can go
keep going higher what you have here is
you trade back into it for one two three
four five bars right and even the six
bars starting right up on the on the
high of the value area so at this point
when you're trading up here you know you
shouldn't be looking for it to start to
sell off so if you're short in here you
got to cover it already in here and then
the market you know starts working its
way back up up up up back into the 80s
okay then we start selling off so again
if you're looking at the charts
right you see what time is it now it's
about 2 40. 248 going into the cash
close we're actually making new highs
let's take a look at that right now
because that's uh sort of a new
development since I started talking
um on this video
um okay so we started moving up from
this lowish area in here you know coming
off coming down we got a bullish primer
point of control
um got the zero print in that bar I mean
I do see this green zone being drawn out
from earlier that's obviously here
that's abandoned value area so that was
holding
um you know start working our way up
starting to see some bullish order flow
uh bullish Prominent Point of control
here again this yellow line is the
opening price
um you do have a abandoned value area
here which is nice but it just sort of
goes sideways pulls back down through
then you get another one here you got a
gap in the value here that's
pretty wide a couple ticks another
abandoned value area so you got one two
abandoned value areas which is a strong
sign on its own right anytime you get
two valuaries that are abandoned like
this that are not traded over the next
into in the next two bars that's a
strong sign and you know we're working
our way back up to new highs up here so
again you know something to look for
abandoned value area abandoned value or
too consecutive right if you just sort
of go back and you look for you know
honestly if you were to go back you know
over time and look for two in a row I
know there was that one early in the day
I don't know if there was any late
here's one two here right this bar this
bar got a little bit of a move down pull
back a little move lower okay
um
uh there's one right after the open
right if you remember
one two all right again pulls back
through the first value area test the
second value area so again if you're
buying somewhere in here in between
these value areas
what is that uh 50 you know 59 or 60
area right up into the 70s so it's a
nice 10 point move
so again you know everybody order flow
is a great tool all right it's not a
it's not a Holy Grail it's not a trading
system by itself it's it's data that you
can analyze and and make
um informed trading decisions off of and
you know a tool like my tool like the
order flow is Trader that's why I
developed it is to help my own trading
in the past I mean I didn't
want to get into selling software but a
lot of people I started sharing it with
some other Traders and they're like hey
can I get a copy when they see my charts
because you know we started adding
certain features onto it and they're
like hey you know what I could use that
in my trading so
it's all about understanding what's
taking place in the market okay nothing
more all right so if you like this video
be sure to hit the Subscribe channel the
Subscribe button rather if you haven't
subscribe to my channel and uh you know
leave some comments I try to
take a look at the comments every once
in a while and you know I do reply every
so often so thanks everyone have a great
day bye-bye